um so a general election uh would
arguably bring many more weeks of
uncertainty isn't it time for some
stability now the risk is not a general
election the risk is continuing with
this chaos what you've seen the last few
weeks is real damage to our economy real
damage to our reputation as a country
and people are paying the price for that
whether it's in mortgages or other
things so the risk is not changing and
there's an alternative you can either
have more of this chaos under the
conservatives or stability under a labor
government stabilize the economy with a
plan for growth a plan for jobs that's
the choice and I think the public are
entitled to their say on that choice
uh lots of candidates being sort of
floated around as options don't you fear
Rishi sunak the most is the next
conservative leader look we've got to
get away from this idea that the sort of
revolving door of chaos and that we just
get the next experiment at the top of
the Tory party what matters is what
happens to this country and there's the
contrast more of this chaos or stability
under a labor government and it's very
important I think that everybody
watching this appreciates we don't have
to go on like this we can have stability
we can have an economy that works for
working people that's why we need a
general election give people a choice do
you want to continue with this chaos
which is damaging the economy or
wouldn't you prefer a labor government
the stability that that will bring for
our country
some are saying Boris Johnson has got
the numbers to make it through to the
membership if he decides to stand what
would you make of that well I remind
myself that only three months ago Boris
Johnson left office because most of
those who were serving him on his front
bench had declared that he was unfit for
office so to go from the Kamikaze budget
under Liz truss back to a man that his
own party is declared is unfit for
offers is the most powerful argument you
could possibly have for a general
election so that we can put the
alternative case to the country which is
stability growth an economy that works
for everyone rather than this chaos
let's just have to resign because of her
economic plans but labor have yet to
unveil there for an economic plan is
that fair
we have set out that we want a fair A
Greener Britain we've set out that what
that means is jobs good jobs secure jobs
across all parts of the United Kingdom
with the infrastructure to back that up
this is a plan that actually recognizes
that our economy needs to work for
working people the contrast with Liz
truss is she believes and the
conservative belief that it's only those
at the top that create our wealth I
fundamentally disagree we've set out our
plan our plan is based on working people
recognize that they create the wealth
and they should benefit from that wealth
morally should trust get the 115 000
pounds a year she's entitled to as a
former prime minister after just 45 days
in office no she shouldn't take that
entitlement after 44 days she has not
earned the right to that in time but in
my view she should turn it down and what
do you make of the Ukraine government
meeting better call
well look I saw that tweet I was rather
surprised by it but look as far as
Ukraine is concerned by you know
absolute imperative is to make sure that
we're all supporting Ukraine in the face
of aggression from Putin so I was
surprised by the Tweet but look in the
circumstances that they face my absolute
focus is on giving Ukraine all the
support we possibly can